your doctor may recommend that you receive
a blood transfusion to treat your
medical condition or to save your life your
blood carries oxygen and nutrients to
all your tissues and removes carbon
dioxide and other waste products from
them your blood also helps fight
inflammation  infection and wound
healing blood is made up of a portion
of fluid and cellular components the
fluid called plasma is where
nutrients hormones
coagulation factors and other chemicals
dissolve
rather than dissolve cellular components are suspended in
plasma are made up of  red blood cells
that carry oxygen and
carbon dioxide
white blood cells that fight
infection
and platelets that are small sub-cells
that help blood to clot
and blood cells are made in
the bone marrow a soft tissue
found inside various  from your bones
a blood transfusion uses
donated blood to replenish
red blood cells white blood cells platelets
clotting factors plasma or
whole blood Circumstances that
may require a blood transfusion include
blood loss from trauma
heart surgery or other major surgery
organ transplant
bleeding disorders such as hemophilia
severe anemia  including sickle cell
anemia treatment for leukemia
or other cancer disorders that
destroy blood cells or
bone marrow or dh incompatibility in
newborns
to start transfusion
an intravenous needle will be inserted into the vein in your
hand or arm
will be hung  A bag containing
the donated blood will be placed near you and the blood will drip
slowly through a tube attached to
the IV needle, allowing it to
flow through your vein into your
bloodstream throughout the transfusion.
Your temperature,
heart rate, breathing, and blood pressure will be monitored
afterward.  the bag  is empty
another bag will be placed on the
IV line in case you need more blood
when the transfusion is finished
the needle will be removed
after the transfusion your doctor will
monitor your vital signs to
make sure you don't have a
bad reaction if necessary
possibly given a  diuretic to reduce
any swelling or fluid retention